So Bruce had found a city niche combo that looks great,
but only found six businesses advertising in the area.
Is this still a go or move on?
Six businesses, I'd still go for it.
I mean, if you are, it shouldn't,
I mean, look, I've gone into cities
that there's been three or two and I've gotten deals.
What we have to remember guys,
is it is still possible to close people
that aren't currently paying for ads or leads.
That's still a thing, right?
Like I feel like before I started talking about it,
people weren't even looking at that shit.
It was just like, we're just going into whatever.
So yes, you can close people that aren't paying.
It's just easier when they're paying for Google ads.
And then it's easier after that paying for people
that are paying, finding people that are paying
for home advisor and then Angie's leads.
And then it goes down, boom, boom, boom, boom.
So at six people paying for it, yeah, bro, send it.
No big deal, just send that thing, dude.
Gotta get in those reps.
And I'm guessing if there's not anyone paying for ads
or only six people, then maybe your CPC is really low.
And if nothing else, you get your reps in, okay?